and jamison taion
towing the slab into boogie down here
tonight
it'll be his 15th start on the season
you can see the numbers across the board
the 20 walks 69 strikeouts 11 homers
been pretty good at all
the best one yet his last start we saw
it clearly the best start as a yankee
he's got a 3.04 er8 home coming into
tonight pitching mode part two i think
he's just mixing it up better doing more
two seamers and change-ups having fun
again i think that's how he finds his
way back walsh one of those guys right
now that is caught in a tough situation
i mean if he played any other position
than first base he'd probably be a
pencil in for the all-star game one two
straight
andrew heaney has completed his warm-up
tosses bottom of the first inning
that one's driven deep to right field
there it
long goes run the other way for sanchez
and the yankees lead one nothing
somebody's smiling virtually a thousand
miles from you guy in a private studio
here to see gary sanchez take a ball out
over the plate away and shoot it away
this is the gary sanchez that i remember
when he came up from the minor leagues
not a dead 4-hitter tremendous power the
other way
a couple good swings last night for jose
iglesias and he was hitting the ball the
other way which is means he's seen the
ball well when he don't get into that
pull mode
into the gap in deep left center field
this one is gone for jose iglesias
a two-round homer puts the angel ahead
2-1 here in the second inning well he
loves hitting in yankee stadium
continues to put up those good swings
3 21 in his career so here's gardner
and these are the situations the yankees
have struggled in with a runner third
and fewer than two outs runner and
scoring position and i've been able to
get it done
fly ball left field
schedler
near the line reaches in and makes the
play tagging and trying to score they
cut the ball off and they'll throw to
second so scoring is shaw and that'll be
a sad fly in a choo-choo game
[Applause]
and that's a great play you know certain
points of the game you don't win and
reaching make that play if it's late in
the game no but in the early part of the
game you trust your offense that's an
outstanding play not only to be able to
catch that but keep that in the glove
the snow cone now here is le mayhew
laced into right field that is a basic
better go into the corner and duhar
scores easily and lamehu
with an rbi single and the yankees lead
three to two
[Applause]
that's his 30th rbi
and here's judge
high drive center field and deep ward
back track one
sam into monument park a two-run home
run for judge and the yankees lead five
to
[Music]
well two most hitters get a hold of one
dead center field you kind of wait not
aaron judge if you saw hidy's reaction
he knew immediately and said aaron judge
some kind of power kyo hey otani will be
the next batter
did he do it again
he got another one
there is no containing this dude
number
27. and it almost looked like he was
slightly out of foot that was a
change-up he hit out
keeps his hands back
and drives it out right center it's
unreal with joey
ohtani is doing 27th home run of the
year
and his smile that's all you can do is
smile go you know what yeah i'm that
good here is luis renifo
to lead it off switch it to batting left
and he drills one to deep right center
on the run is judge and he makes a great
catch i mean a fabulous catch i never
thought he'd get it he stole a double or
maybe even a triple away from renipo
he made a backhand catch down by his
ankles in the uh right near the bullpen
in right center you know he just did
something i've never seen him do he is
so happy with himself he made this great
catch he keeps running he's got a big
smile on his face you know usually he's
so professional he is so happy he made
that catch i'm glad he's showing that
emotion and here is and too hard to lead
it off
and the pitch is swung on hit in the air
to right field that ball is high it is
far it is gone
miguel and duhar goes the opposite way
and drives one in the right field seats
the dew
can do
and he's getting miggy with it he homers
to right and the yankees take a 6-3 lead
and i love it there's that approach
going the opposite way he's they're very
he throws first bit strikes all the time
first and second always strikes they're
going the other way that's that's what
we've expected this whole time
not too late near gary sanchez
runner goes that one is lined to left
field that's gonna be a base hit
and it's gonna go to the wall that
allows gardner to score easily it's an
rbi double for sanchez and it's 7-3
yanks
that one is ripped into center field
ward back it's going to be over his head
one hop up against the wall sanchez
scores stanton will stop at third it's
an rbi double for point and the yankees
are pouring it on they lead eight three
one one
and there's the base hit through the
vacated hole on the right side
one run scores here comes point here's
the throw he's in there it is a two-run
single for clever torres boy did he need
that 10-3 yanks
[Music]
at the play to shohei
that one's hit well
and that one's gone again
he did it again
[Applause]
get off me bring that fastball into my
hands get off me
how do you turn on that pitch there
unless you're superman
how quick those hands are for show a
otani
oh man look at this spot yeah in those
hands
[Applause]
that is a rocket hit out miggy has
singled homered and ground it up
lined into left field it is a basic
scoring easily as tourists
or sheller will go to third it's an rbi
double board in duhar
and he is three for four and the yankees
lead 11-5